that's not the plan
Jayden I'm curious
um obviously we know you as
his baby mama right
I mean obviously I'm sure he takes care
of his kids but prior to you being uh
starting this musical career are you do
you have like a gig do you work like
what's your what do you what what are
you doing one day no
um I used to whoa before he did this I
used to work but yeah that's real
no he ever since he when he got on and I
had to work which is you know God said
that I I don't know I'm not ungrateful
I'm not ungrateful but I'm doing it
forever to you so you've never had to
work yeah since he blew up no oh wow not
a second not a day I don't have to there
were certain things I did just because I
was like yeah I want to do that or I
want to start this or I want to start
that I did a skin thing um that was I
was doing a whole like skin care uh
treatment room before I had my second
kid okay but after that one I kind of
was like oh my God two kids is crazy
that was something I kind of like yeah
like he wanted me to find something that
I like to do right
I don't mind paying for you but like
what do you want to do she's like I
don't know I don't know I don't know
like I wanted to be a boss or something
and I and I just knew that if I couldn't
be a boss or something until like I was
skilled in it myself you know what I
mean because how am I going to tell
someone to do something and I don't know
how to do it I went to esthetician
school I funded a paper fire yeah and
then so you can do uh some facial I can
wax I can do all that yeah her own
parlor she was hiring people and shaving
I was [__] with it but I don't think
it was like her job I think it was just
I wanted to be a boss but I wanted like
then I wanted someone to like
micromanage that like tell me what
everyone's doing you know what I mean I
wanted to get to that point and I was
almost to that point and then I got
pregnant again and then I had the second
baby and it kind of it definitely slowed
me down you know
um because I just I couldn't keep up
keep up with everything like and it was
it was about like 30 minutes away from
where I was at so I was just like
who can keep up with me and then whoever
was there ended up doing some weird [__]
to me I had to kick her out like yeah I
just drove by your uh
defunct restaurant yeah
yeah yeah because was your mom running
out they just fixed the the windows and
[__] my mom was running it I mean that's
probably the problem huh
now I'm always running it and we just
kind of fell out and then I mean we've
seen yes he's like kind of like I just
fell off but I partnered with somebody
else um you should put one in her Hood
over there in the valley and make it
like Ceviche bro like you know the
Mexicans
gotta go straight Mariscos bro I'm
trying to go Seafood around you know the
bag you know like they charge you like
crab legs yeah like crab legs and corn
and potatoes
that's our really favorite food for real
I love we love that so I partnered with
this crab place and then they go so I
got the building I got the place and
then we just gonna go 50 50 and maybe
crack his crab legs for them
crabs
speak to that uh uh yeah dude you have a
really tumultuous relationship with your
mom I think I said that word wrong by
the way
um but is there any repair in that
because shit's gotten super
my mom is far gone brother
I feel like when people get around me
so I can get poisoned by like clout fans
and followers and attention and then
it's like
I'm not gonna fight with you about it
I'm not gonna call you and be like hey
why did you do this why did you do that
I'm gonna just be like
the more I see you going your way I'm
Gonna Go My Way you've been around this
mom a long time a long time do you kind
of see the night and day of it because I
think that she yeah you know her too I
think that honestly I think that she
doesn't take the internet as seriously
that it is like
she'll like post something and then not
think it's that serious but then it is
that and then it's everywhere you know
what I mean and like because it's a
reflection and she's a she's a Leo so I
kind of I have like I want to say three
or four Leos in my life so I know that
they like they can get angry or they'll
want to say something and then they'll
say it and then be like that was crazy
was when she talked about the size of
your manhood I was like this should not
you know I just
I just see it I'm scared my dick way
bigger no I don't know because I just
think that I think that it is way more I
think she said it in a way that she
didn't mean it as like that but right
people people dissect and take things in
a way different way that you like he
could post something right now and it'll
be so not like that they'll dissect it
slow it down who's in the back what's on
the counter that's the type of that's
where we live at though that's the
generation right now like they want to
find something wrong so she she is
giving them everything she is crazy she
is all that we but you like that's who
she's always been she's always been you
still get to see the kids yeah she does
I do I handle that more so than him he
doesn't I don't listen who look here I
don't want to be in charge of no kids I
don't want to be responsible
this is great no I will look listen let
me Land wait let me land the kids are
fine let me laugh I mean listen oh
that's why I don't get finished okay
that's why she hasn't worked because I
know you know when I have kids with
people I I don't like
people
exactly one experience but yeah but when
I had kids with her I was always happy I
was always sure I was always like
I'm not a babysitter bro I'm a provider
a leader protector that's what a man is
to me somebody who's going to provide
lead and protect that's all I know how
to do so you're not interested in like a
day with the kids at Disneyland just you
know definitely he could never do he
could definitely do that though that's
about it though maybe if they're maybe
if they're like like walking they can go
in the bathroom
no diapers no bottles none of that like
we all eat the same thing and stuff
maybe absolutely then he I I think he
could yeah corn dog but diaper bag
formula he is so nice I gotta get out
there and get it bro yeah okay
I'm a baby how am I making any money for
the baby so you're not doing the
airplane and you know how much it cost
to raise a baby
I have grown children there's 12 months
in a year that's 120 000.
ten thousand dollars a month it costs
ten thousand dollars I mean
I know it costs for your baby to have a
room a bed
a school a ride to school food to eat at
school
it costs ten thousand dollars a month
my kid's living well
hey I every every kid should live well I
liked it I liked it I should live well
depending on what happens with this kid
that you're expecting we might want to
walk back that figure a little to maybe
like three thousand dollars a month in
case they come at you for child support
no I'm not worried about that
because
I've made her good enough to use her
she's good she can use her name anywhere
and get anything she she wants she
doesn't need you know
so I'm not making her dependent of me I
didn't for you you're not interested in
babysitting I can bro I'ma provide lead
and protect and babysit
I mean it's it's possible
yeah for one two days maybe even three
days